die lage erst rückwärts betrachtet egal
ich habe mich natürlich auf das gespräch
vorbereitet oder man muss immer nach
vorne gucken
okay die momentane lage ist sehr gut
muss ich sein ich bin gesund meiner
familie geht es gut meinen freunden geht
es gut und die musik läuft und bei punkt
läuft und rap sparen läuft und jetzt
hier im interview bei pixum zu sagen so
ein ritterschlag er neue cd kommt jetzt
neue cd kommt jetzt raus maxime neues
macht mal lärm
die erste wirklich so amtliche im
plastik damals habe ich auch einfach
namen für ual case you a case nicht
tools kennen es ja beim anderen thema
genauer bonk du bist neu im cast juhls
ist raus und da gab es heftige
diskussionen wie habt ihr das
mitbekommen heftig also war natürlich
auch schade
ich bin jetzt aber nicht der grund warum
der osten ist sondern das ist ja
stellung das gesagt was gesagt dass du
bist ja ich bin jetzt seit juli und das
ist ja auch sowieso eine ständig
wechselnde sache ich finde oder man
sieht auch dass die leute das so lange
machen wie es ihnen spaß macht so pcrm
waren wir da haben wir super erfolg mit
ihrem kanal joyce ist jetzt auch in
verschiedenen formaten unterwegs und
aber die leute kommen ja auch immer noch
mal wieder sonne zum beispiel elf gramm
barren jetzt auch noch mal da oder
willst es auch immer herzlich willkommen
die leute nehmen das nur von außen immer
so krass war
sie sehen dann halt ja der ist jetzt
draußen und warum ist er nicht mehr da
das geld ist ja dass die leute ihren
eigenen kanal haben bei mir ist jetzt
ein bisschen anders rum ich hatte vorher
schon gute zulauf auf meinem kanal und
bin jetzt halt quasi bei punkt aber für
mich ist es halt so eine coole sache
verrückt zu sein oder man was erleben
wir zum beispiel diese deutschland
challenge oder
was war das ja der kampf auf einmal auf
die idee ihr habt da zwei handys mit
navigation und messenger und wasser sich
und ich kriege jeder 100 euro guckt wie
weiterkommt hat gesagt seinen worten
verpisst euch auch großen mann hat
gesagt wer weiterkommt und sebastian und
ich also jacket jim redman und joyce und
mark und ich sind dann los gestartet
witzigerweise den süden in den norden
und wir mussten dann gucken wie weit wir
kommen und bis zum nächsten tag dann
quasi wieder zurück mit diesen 100 euro
und dazu einfach eine coole erfahrung
ich selber bin jetzt total gespannt auf
das material vom zweiten teil ich hab
mir jetzt den ersten teil vorher
angeguckt bin super gespannt auf den
zweiten teil weil es einfach spaß macht
es hat auch spaß gemacht dabei zu sein
und ich habe jetzt deren seite noch
nicht gesehen habe ich noch nicht
gesehen was sebastian joyce dann
wirklich noch gemacht haben wir mussten
uns inzwischen durch die whatsapp
standorte schicken so ein bisschen wie
europareise kennst du haben nun auch
zwischen eines challengers bekommen die
wir dann lösen mussten und hat einfach
super viel spaß gemacht
okay das heißt was ist für dich kommt
ist für mich eine möglichkeit ein
bisschen was den leuten von meiner
persönlichkeit zu zeigen
ich bin noch ganz ehrlich ich muss dass
er selber dann nicht schneiden so da
haben wir leute weil meine eigene musik
videos schneidig ja nur diese sachen
muss ich wahrscheinlich kann einfach so
sein wie ich bin kein bisschen witzig
sein
mit netten leuten zusammen sein also zum
beispiel chain hat mich ja damals
angerufen und gesagt hast du bock dabei
zu sein und der ist halt echt ein
topteam fenster ist halt ein top typ
das ist eine super liebe der jools mit
dem habe ich auch viel spaß gehabt
freestyle auf der straße und so weiter
die base ist ein kleiner typ von
bullshit tv und sowieso sebastian ich
war damit mark unterwegs und wie das
dann ist wenn du wirklich 36 stunden am
stück dann irgendwo unterwegs bist am
anfang redet man noch so oberflächlich
und irgendwann dann packt er eine
ausnahme packte andere auch aus und man
kommt den leuten natürlich ein bisschen
näher
was ist punkt für mich punkt macht spaß
verfügen und ein kanal hat sich dadurch
auch noch mal stärker entwickelt absolut
ja
obwohl du bist dann auch in youtube
urgestein muss man sagen wann hast du
angefangen
ich habe angefangen 2009 habe ich den
kanal registriert aber
bestimmt gar nicht früher auf die welt
also 2009 kam ein erstes video
und das war noch richtig billig sowie
gut äckern wo bist du mein sonnenlicht
irgendwo auf einer burg gesessen und da
so videos von gemacht halt alles
verbessert sich ich habe aber letztens
noch gesehen kennt ihr diese analytics
funktion wird er jetzt so wurde die die
zuschauer quasi sehen kannst waren sich
alle abonnierten gesehen du hast mich
abonniert am 14.12.2009 wieder so lange
her dass er schon viel bei utah dann
bist du mir irgendwie fand ich
sensationell
ja das war auch richtig hammer es gibt
ja immer so einzelne schübe damals soll
das dann bei hertz intakt so dann kam
eigentlich alles was dann kam ziemlich
gut an jedes video hatte dann über
hunderttausend klicks dann kam er noch
hier zu dem außenseiter film therapie
der soundtrack renault die man uns
wahrscheinlich gefragt haben ob ich
einen song machen
und ja jetzt durch punkt klar die leuten
denen das dann gefällt dann ist ja immer
so eine sache wie viele wir haben fast
500.000 abonnenten und nicht jeder
schaut natürlich jedes video aber wenn
du dich dann sehen zum beispiel jetzt
mein auftritt bei der google party oder
dieses freestyle mit jools und so weiter
unsere oder diese halt einmal gesehen
ruf mich an beruf nicht angenommen werde
ich an mit dem handy da diese anrufe
nicht an
doch naja hab ich gesehen und wenn das
den leuten mehr helcom natürlich rüber
auf deine kann haben gucken sich das an
ok also für einige drin auftauchen
absolute absoluter vorteil also es gab
natürlich viele von meinen fans die dann
gesagt haben es ist keine zeit mehr für
deine musik oder das passt vielleicht
nicht zu deinem image aber dann haben
die leute vielleicht ein falsches bild
von meinem image gehabt weil mein image
ist eigentlich dass ich kein image habe
ich versuche also du bist ja auch du
bist ja als journalist auch er seriöse
mit den leuten redet was ja nicht heißt
es nämlich auch mal auf die kacke haus
oder vielleicht ein döner ist irgendwie
oder
genauso auf chlor ist wie alle anderen
auch und das ist schön dass man das bei
pommes zu zeigen kann und ich bin auf
jeder der zu meinen konzerten gekommen
ist oder zu diesen straßen konzerten und
egal wo hat mich auch immer als
positiven und lebensfrohen menschen
erlebt und das kann ich immer punkt auch
sein
und das bist du auch ja also was ist
eine dunkle seite
das würde ich so nicht sagen dass ich
keine dunkle härter weise nicht
vielleicht muss ich dir also sage ich
mal so viele meiner lieder sind ja recht
traurig sind ja auch also wie soll man
eine dunkle seite definieren ich finde
das viel blödsinn auf der welt abgeht
wie das jetzt hier sagen kann aber zur
not geschneit sodass raus ich habe
vorgestern irgendwas bei facebook
gesehen so eine meldung von wegen hier
drei kamen die helfen verkamen von von
weiter weg und drei mädels zwischen 12
und 18 jahren und die haben welten tot
getreten und habe ich halt dieses video
gesehen aber nur bis zur hälfte war ich
echt nicht weiterkommen könnte es gibt
halt leute die haben so ein fetisch
dafür dass junge mädchen mit ihren füßen
egal ob insekten oder tiere dann tot
treten
und ich meine klar da würde sich in
jedem normalen menschen von uns
übergehen aber das sind so momente wo
ich mir denke so was geht ab wie kann
also diese mädchen selber an das nicht
gemacht sondern steckte dann so ein
ehepaar dahinter die das hat aufgenommen
und auch produziert haben und irgendwie
kriegt man dafür irgendwo auf der welt
wohl geld aber das sind halt sachen oder
zum beispiel herz intakt wenn du einfach
auf dem moment kommt so warum gibt es
menschen die verdienen milliarden
ich meine jeder soll das geld verdienen
wenn er arbeitete so ist ja auch in
ordnung die einen verdienen mehr die
anderen weniger auch je nach talent und
und so nur warum manche menschen
milliarden und wissen dabei aber dass
irgendwo in bangladesch oder irgendwo
auf der welt menschen krepieren ja nicht
nur unter schlechten bedingungen
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger fliegt
sondern kreieren damit die sich ihr
säcke voll machen was sie in ihrem leben
nicht mehr ausgeben können und das
konnte ich dann zum beispiel damals
beherzte da konnte ich es nicht
verstehen und hab dann diesen song
geschrieben und
das ist schon immer noch so eine seite
die in mir hoch kommt dieses sensible
dieses emotionale und das aber meistens
werde ich halt alleine bin meistens
nachts meistens irgendwie auch in der
dunklen jahreszeit aber generell
versuche ich halt das leben positiv zu
sehen wie es us cent zusammen dieses ist
ja schon
ich kann mir vorstellen ja auch fertig
macht ihr aber ich bin sehr dankbar fürs
leben dadurch dass ich sehe dass andere
leute nichts ohne chance haben ich finde
das sehr wichtig auch zu sehen
beispielsweise jetzt punkt ist eine
super chance ich bin gerne da ich halte
mich da gerne auf videos irgendwo
einzustellen dass tausende leute oder
millionen sogar die sehen können ist
eine chance für mich ist das leben
morgens aufzuwachen ist ein geschenk und
ich nehme das dankbar an und bedanke
mich dann dadurch dass ich etwas tue und
dass sie auch freund ich bin zu anderen
menschen und im endeffekt ist es so dass
wenn jetzt jemand hinterlistig ist oder
anderen menschen etwas schlechtes tut
ich glaube auch an sowas wie karma das
ist halt zu den zurückkommt und ich habe
das auch schon oft genug gemerkt
und selbst wenn ich könnte das anders
ich bin lieber im reinen mit mir selber
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger oder hat
vielleicht einen längeren weg aber bin
dann glücklich und kann in den spiegel
kommt und kommt denn dieses positive
kammer zu dir zurück vollblut klar
also wenn du ich bin hier zum beispiel
durch deutschland gereist war in
frankfurt düsseldorf köln aus der
lombardei und und hamburg jetzt an zb
noch am wochenende und habe mich dann
mit leuten getroffen neues musikvideo
gedreht
und da kommt immer so viel positive
resonanz kann er das gerne erklärt
zerstört das uns sonst der nase lang ja
da geht so ein bisschen daten ist jetzt
da nicht drauf sommer sommer lieber über
neues radio oder sein
das ist halt so da hat die mit ihm ich
angerufen weil ich war so ein bisschen
ich weiß nicht ob du diese zweifel
kennst du was soll ich machen wo soll
ich lang gehen
welchen weg soll ich gehen und dann hat
sie gesagt weißt du was machst du bist
kein schlechter mensch mach einfach mach
einfach mal und dann wird das schon
irgendwie habe ich darüber nachgedacht
wie ein schatz den wir danach aber ich
hab dann irgendwie nur der nase lang
blieb dann auch so und wenn du dann
sonst von aufnimmst und das video dazu
rausbringt und das hat jetzt auch
irgendwie weise nicht fast 400.000
klicks leute auf der straße kommen zu
dir und sagen aber ich war eine therapie
ich war in der kur ich war da und da und
dieses lied hat mir aber wieder kraft
gegeben weiterzumachen und das ist halt
auch ein schönes gefühl
das gibt dir selber ja auch so eine
gewisse wertigkeit also früher als ich
angefangen habe lieder zu schreiben weil
das halt für mich selber so eine
therapie
deswegen konnte ich auch diesen fällen
von sascha und die mal so fühlen als
halt einfach so wahr ich hatte meine
probleme mit mir selbst und mit der welt
und fand mich selber auch nicht so
korrekt ich habe früher auch gelogen ich
habe auch mal gestohlen ich habe auch
drogen genommen
ich will das auch gar nicht
verheimlichen ja die leute die sich mit
der sache beschäftigen müssen ja immer
das ganze sehen wenn ihr nur einen song
an
zum beispiel jetzt motivation dann
denken die der liebsten nur seine mama
und es soll das muttersöhnchen wenn
leute in den augen seiner mutter sehen
diesen mit einem rap dann denken die
bodes volle kasse rapper und so nehmen
die leute aber wenn dir das ganze sehen
würde ich von mir selber behaupten dass
ich eigentlich authentischer bin als
viele andere musiker die immer nur eine
schiene machen also wenn du haftbefehl
bist und du machst immer nur ghetto und
immer nur ich bin der hatte er liebt
auch seine mutter wahrscheinlich oder
hat auch seine gefühle und jemand wie
xavier naidoo hat früher auch sehr viel
gerappt und hat auch
der türsteher zum beispiel hat der
kampfsport gemacht ich ja erst früher
vorne
der ist groß was immer gesehen eines
groß und der ist auch sehr gut dabei und
ich meine einfach nur so sind wir
ehrlich wir haben viele seiten an uns
und durch dieses texte schreiben das war
für mich immer so eine art von tagebuch
ich hab auch schon mit 11 oder so damit
angefangen aber wenn du schon mit elf
angefangen hast wie kriegst oder wie ist
da dann die geschichte gewesen dass du
sagst du hast auch du eine schlechte
zeit gelogen und so weiter und so fort
wie fühlt sich das zusammen du hast ja
mit elf noch andere probleme als mit 16
und schreibst ja nicht die ganze zeit
muss auch in die schule gehen
ja aber ich sag mal so wenn man es kann
ja auch mit elf schon so eine richtung
sich ergeben aber offen sichtbar dir ja
nicht sondern würdest du sagen diese
zeit der pubertät war dann ich bin auf
abwege bekommen absolut wer also früher
war ja noch ganz anders war als kind in
der grundschule und ich war mal und auch
durch meine dicke brille
früher gab es auch nicht diese
umrechnung leser ja früher ich hatte so
wirklich acqua di sa so richtig und dann
auch so rund und so habe ich aber auch
schon in diesem video mit der zeit fotos
auch ein geändertes schäme mich auch
nicht dafür nur damals war alles echt
super ich habe eine zeitlang in götting
gelegt er in ein neues geboren werden in
göttingen gelebt weil meine mutter das
studiert hat und da war einfach ein ganz
anderes leben noch da war irgendwie
studentenstadt und auf der wiese auf dem
reiterhof oder was weiß ich was uns ging
werden nie viel geld aber meine mutter
hat immer sehr viel gegeben und dann
sind als rhythmus gekommen und dann war
sie dieses typische freunde verloren
auch so dieses ganze bekannte soziale
umfeld verloren und dann kommt auf
einmal hin und willst dann neue freunde
finden wird vielleicht nicht unbedingt
direkt irgendwie aufgenommen haben
willst natürlich mit den coolen sein
nirgendwo auf der natur zu höchster
stadtteil da und dann wurde halt gekifft
dass irgendwelche leute kennengelernt
und lee so ergeben sich immer wieder
neue zeiten würdest du sagen du wärst
wenn da nicht die richtige du die kurve
gekriegt hätte es auf die schiefe bahn
geraten oder würdest du sagen ich mal
auf der schiefen bahn stück weit war ich
auf jeden fall angepfiffen
das heißt was wir straftaten machen
lange reise klingt die keine ob die
keiner kennt doch natürlich die leute
die damals damit zu tun hatten can be
solches jetzt erzählen
ja ich glaube schon ich sage einfach mal
so wenn du gibst dann besorg dir was zu
rauchen und irgendwann lernst du
vielleicht per zufall jemanden kennen
der dir eine größere menge zu einem
günstigeren preis verkauft ob er mal
hast du das mit dir dabei raus und dann
sagt jemand
das ist aber viel das ist doch bestimmt
für 20 mark nun sagst du nehmen die das
nur für zehn mark damals auf dem markt
sagt der wahl kann es mir vielleicht das
nächste mal was mitbringen und dann
besorgt sie vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
bringt dem navas mit und auf einmal
denkst du die summen im ok jetzt wird er
was haben für jemanden den ich gar nicht
kenne
gut dann nehme ich mir davon 121 weg
gibt es in deutschland das ist nichts
worauf ich heutzutage stolz ende das
will ich ganz deutlich sagen und da bin
ich auch sehr froh dass ich dann
irgendwie bei erwischt wurde
aber genau wie jetzt mit den
außenseitern oder wie mit dieser pong
geschichte oder so hatte ich
komischerweise immer ob er das jetzt
positionen gingen aber ich hatte immer
schon den vorteil
oder das glück an krasse leute zu
geraten das war leider auch damals im
negativen so dass ich einfach an leute
geraten wenn sie damit kilos zu tun
hatten
und das war noch mal hatte ich nicht
erwischt mich war das nie der ich ja
auch nie wieder auf der straße herum
gelaufen dass das immer so ein
freundeskreis halt gemacht so aber das
ist halt wie gesagt nichts worauf ich
stolz bin aber war damals dann einfach
so eine sache auch die sich einfach so
ergeben und ansonsten ansonsten
straftaten wenn du dir meine musik
videos angucken da stecken ja schon in
jedem zweiten bestraft hatte ich gehe
nirgendwo hin springen irgendwo runter
und schleiche mich irgendwo
100 zu filmen du brauchst du
normalerweise für alles über eine
genehmigung ja aber das ist wenn man
kein hausverbot bekommt in der situation
zum beispiel 1 mio was war das
urlaubsreif so ein sommer party song da
bin ich bei uns im haus gibt es
mittlerweile nicht mehr gibt so beach
strand sand aufgeschüttet auch richtig
mit schiff und alles nicht in extra
morgens um 5 uhr hin weil schon die
sonne geschienen hat ein anderer ein
geklettert und da ist sogar auf der
aufnahme im video ist noch dieses drin
wo dann die tür aufgeht und was machen
sie denn da und so war dann auch
eingestellt
nur das sind alles sachen die ich
heutzutage wo ich hinter stehen kann wo
hast du denn die kurve gekriegt die
kurve gekriegt also wann hast du gemerkt
verdammt hier wasser quasi auf dem weg
zum dealer wie hast du die kurve
gekriegt weil ich habe hat ja
wahrscheinlich gut davon leben oder
meine ecke davon gut leben können ja
aber das hat dann bei mir eigentlich so
den verlauf genommen dass ich irgendwann
auch aufgehört habe zu kiffen und dann
also es gibt ja auch leute die mit
irgendwas handeln und selber land nichts
zu tun haben aber für mich war das halt
wirklich so der alltag dass ich
irgendwas geraucht habe und an anderen
was mitgebracht hat und ganz ehrlich
durch die musik ich habe zum beispiel
letztens auch gelesen schon vorn hat
jetzt auch aufgehört zu helfen wegen
seiner stimme
es ist einfach so du brauchst eine
gewisse kondition du brauchst auch eine
gewisse vom kiffen wird er auch der hals
trocken der mund wird trocken nur cars
gar nicht diese power und wenn du dann
auf einmal auftritte hast von 1 23
stunden länge brauchst du einfach diese
kraft und da war mir die musik dann
immer wichtiger als das kiffen
das heißt die musik durch also man sagt
ihr das ja nach die positive wirkung
aber sie hat auch wirklich eine ganz
konkrete absolut anleger aber in jeder
hinsicht also ich habe dadurch so viele
freunde kennengelernt so viele tolle
menschen ich habe so viele orte bereist
das liebe ich liebe das reisen ich liebe
die die welt kennenlernen und
auch diese selbstreflexion einfach es
ist wirklich so ohne quatsch muss mich
für verrückt halten ja ich weiß nicht
wie ich das bestand soll du manchmal
wache ich nachts auf ich habe so ein
blog neben meinem bett liegen um stift
und manchmal wache ich nachts auf und
schreibe etwas irgendwie im halbschlaf
wie wenn du das gar nicht kraft was
macht dann später wieder auflebt mir das
durch und denke mir wie krass ich bin
selber geflasht davon oder oder
begeistert davon was ich da lese und
wenn ich dann zum beispiel niedriger
also nicht dass ich mich jetzt total
geil finde ich feiere viel musik und
auch viele filme und so aber wir selber
gibt es halt total
und wenn das nicht wäre würde ich
wahrscheinlich auch sein spiel damals
nach herzinfarkten so viele gesagt er
macht doch mal nur so sozialkritische
songs das ist voll deine schiene gema
voll drauf ab oder du machst du
irgendeine ballade und die leute sagen
singen doch nur du kannst so schön
singen rappen das was für leute die mich
sehen können aber dass ich brauche halt
genau diese verschiedenen dinge um das
was ich erlebe zu verarbeiten und das
auch irgendwo als erfahrung wegzustecken
als mein okay wer kann ich gut verstehen
das heißt also in jeglicher hinsicht sie
ist präsent hatte ich auf dem richtigen
weg gebracht und sie hilft dir auch
immer weiter den weg das quasi so
navigations ist voll
es ist quasi wie mein tagebuch dass wir
immer wieder durch lese und ja einfach
nur so zu schreiben wäre mir zu
langweilig die rhetorische frage von was
liebst du eigentlich
ich hab einzelhandelskaufmann dunkeln
bei real war auch eher zufällig wollte
eigentlich hatte ich gar keinen planten
manche wollte musik machen ich habe auch
immer musik gemacht
egal ob auf hochzeiten gesungen oder in
irgendwelchen rap
bettels aber damals war das nicht im
internet sondern ermöglichen hallen wo
du dann gerettet hast alles gemacht und
dann war ich auf der you messe die war
damals noch in essen
und da war ein stand von rez colletti
institut für präklinische notfallmedizin
in essen
und da haben die dann will ich bin halt
von bühne zu bühne getingelt bin zu
jeder bühne paradies das kein product
placement jetzt aber ich bin eine
anhängerin daran erinnere ich mich noch
an die wärme bühne und hat dann immer
gesagt kann ich hier auftreten hatte so
meine instrumental zu den beiden jungs
klar kommen bis zum nächsten mal kann
nicht auftreten ja klar kommt und die
haben dann gesagt ey du bist so cool und
deine texte passen tut unserem konzept
hast du nicht lust jetzt die restlichen
tage hier auch aufzutreten du bist nach
hause gefahren wieder abgeholt habe ich
gesagt ja klar super und darüber habe
ich dann in den pausen auch dieses
institut kennen gelernt und wie die
leute retten und ich hab mir gedacht wie
geil du kannst den menschen was gutes
tun institut für präklinische also quasi
auf dem weg zur klinik notfallmedizin
okay das geht halt sagen was im
krankenwagen vom unfall bis zum captain
und dann hab ich also ich hab dann der
rettungsassistent wo ich mache es ja der
realität der rettungsassistent fand ich
super spannend habe dann auch diesen
ganzen schulischen teil gemacht und so
du lernst du alles warum fließt gut ich
konnte noch nicht mal blut sehen
er war also richtig so irre keine
spritzen und so und dadurch dass du dann
weißt warum gibt es spritzen und was
passiert da ging das nur mit dem
praktischen teil hatte ich dann probleme
da war halt dann einfach so ich weiß
noch genau eine szene da war dann so
motorradfahrer und diesel war super
sportlich auch und hatte frau und zwei
kinder
und die kamen hat damals gesagt ja kommt
der durch unsere standards und gesagt
'ja ja sieht super aus der ist ja
sportlich und so also wenn man wirklich
geschafft ist und er hat es nicht
geschafft und dann guckt also menschen
in die augen und
bis dann schwierig das zu verarbeiten
und ich habe damals mit leuten geredet
und viel haben wir gesagt entweder du
wirst halt auch privat recht kühl
das soll so ernst diese sache nicht mehr
nicht ran zu lassen aber der lässt auch
andere sachen ich mein ich dann an dich
ran und das war auch für mich keine
option weil ich ja so ein
reflektierender typ bin oder viele leute
nehmen auch chemische drogen und nachdem
ich ja dann schon mal ein spaß mit dem
gras gehabt da habe ich mir gedacht so
was braucht auf gar keinen fall und habe
dann immer noch samstags nebenbei bei
real gearbeitet in der ganzen zeit um
das geld zu verdienen ist halt so was
privates gewesen
und die haben dann gemerkt dass es mir
nicht so gut gegen angesagt max was los
und so ich hab den das erzählt so dass
ich da nicht so zufrieden
beziehungsweise das nicht mehr schaffe
und habe gesagt dann macht er bei uns
eine ausbildung und auf einmal habe ich
dann da leberwurst versäumt eine kasse
gesessen und war auf jeden fall spannend
ich liebe ja die arbeit mit menschen
aber ob das dann irgendwann der bisher
die leberwurst versäumt oder jemandem
gesagt wie er die leberwurst verräumen
soll oder im büro sitzt wo du planst wie
jemand jemandem gesagt wer die
leberwurst vor allem soll das bleibt
dann die leberwurst und dann habe ich
gott sei dank dann um auf deine frage
hängt zu kennen habe ich dann irgendwann
diesen sprung geschafft aber über viele
kleine eier mehr und mehr zeit in die
musik zu investieren und dann davon ein
stück weit leben zu können weil es wäre
jetzt nicht wie ein könig ja ich lebe
immer noch in derselben wohnung wie vor
sechs jahren immer noch
ich habe zum beispiel kein auto ich lebe
recht spartanisch aber was ich halt
merke ich kann immer mehr geld in die
videos stecken kann immer mehr reisen
auf mich nehmen einfach mal geld
bezahlen um leute auch zu treffen bis
hin zu investieren und eine cd pressen
wenn man jetzt diese cd nimmt was wie
würdest du die stilrichtung beschreiben
ist das so wie du beschreibst das ist
mal also das gericht sicher
unterschiedlich oder hast du jetzt
gesagt ich mach ein album aus einem guss
das muss alles 1 1 fiel sein dass also
das könnte ich gar nicht da müsste ich
dann wahrscheinlich zehn jahre warten
und hätte dann für jeden stil 20 lieder
das ist man könnte seine narren
breakdance hip hop musik so okay ganz
bunter mix ich würde sagen der rote
faden bei dem album ist das ist alles
deutschsprachig
es geht ums leben
da kann man ganz klar sein so ist es
jetzt nicht unbedingt der absolute party
song drauf und auch nicht irgendwie der
ich mache ich alle fertig mutter fisher
song sondern es geht halt ins reale
leben und die beats sind halt in einem
weg von meinem produzenten nico tau
gemacht der sich halt auch mit mir
entwickelt auch immer weiter die sounds
klingen jetzt organischer früher bei den
cds wasser über sowie hatte noch nicht
mal die lieder hatten und ich meine
gleiche lautstärke alle jetzt haben wir
wirklich in der produktions tiefe auch
gearbeitet und das ist der rote faden
ansonsten max ein neues von rap über pop
bis rock rap du machst auch mit beim
raps war ja komisch komisch nicht ich
hab ich hatte nicht mehr mit als ich
erzählt aktueller hätte ich jetzt nicht
gesagt und das ist auch noch mutter
wobei das ja auch sehr schnell ist
dieses wodurch die tiere farben
verblasst sie tragen den hass ob der
staat sie in den lagern stimmt aber es
ist aber wo ist die grenze zwischen rap
und gesang also für mich zum beispiel
rap einfach nur weniger melodisch und
schneller und gesang deshalb melodischen
und rap nicht die moderne form des
gedichtes sprich gesunden ja sein wird
seine sportlich sind sie wenn sie sich
rechts gesprochenen wichtig weil man
hört ja jetzt auch rap der sich nicht
gar nicht mehr erwartet immer darauf
dass irgendwas 11 will das jetzt nicht
aus es gibt apps wo ich dann nichts mehr
was ich zum beispiel wie man das gedicht
ich will jetzt niemand anschauen habe
ich hab plötzlich jemanden gehabt
also ich hab die räume sucht weil es ja
ich daran dass man darauf wartet was hat
er was hat er gefunden was jetzt auch
darauf rein reimt und dann noch einen
sinn und also ich finde es gibt keine
regeln beim rap es gibt so leute ich
lese ist jetzt unter diesen rap
sparringrunden so oder hatte aber einen
zweck reingebracht zum beispiel netzwerk
raum ist wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel
sage oh ich bin unterwegs mit christoph
krachten heute muss ich auch meine
wortwahl achten wo soll ich heute
übernachten was dann gar nicht mehr
eigentlich zu dem eigentlichen sinn erst
weil es vielleicht schlecht weil ich
auch nichts weg räume bringen aber
wenn man irgendwas bringst maus haus und
damit ist damit es sich rein und dann
wird dann silben werden gezählt dies
anders ein beispiel ich bin noch kein
großer bushido fenja ja aber bushido
schreibt seine texte nicht selber
bushido rappt so wie es eigentlich fast
jeder könnte aber der hat was
was ihn auch zumindest so lange zeit ja
dass wir es heute aussieht aber zu einem
erfolg sehr erfolgreichen rapper gemacht
hat diese stimme die seine aura diese
wirkung auch und natürlich auch mit
seinem optischen gitter wird was dich
berührt wenn so ein harter typ auf
einmal von von gefühlen erzählt und von
von der endlosigkeit und diese das
berührt auch weiß ich meinen also da
muss gar keine große technik dahinter
sein damit es ein guter rap song zum
beispiel kollegah kann geil rappen und
und bringt das ganze auch darüber aber
nicht weil die man so schnell retten
kann kommt dass auch die real rüber und
linker hand aber dazu auch eben
wahnsinnige wortspiele ja absoluter
wahnsinn modelle denkbar denn ihr fett
ab ich meine nur die kunst ist nicht
immer schneller zu rappen ein uns immer
brutaler zu sein sondern die kunst ist
es jemand zu berühren und das kannst du
auch mit einer ganz einfachen zeile ja
aber auch zu verblüffen vielleicht also
also ich ja eher verblüffen sowie
moneyball ja jetzt alle verblüfft habe
aber auch eine nummer
doch irgendwie pr irgendwas hat er doch
studieren in österreich 100 jahren
gedacht da zieht aber schon ganz gut ich
mal mit scheiße kommst du immer schnell
raus ich halt nur die frage wurde dann
hin
die farbe hat immer wo ist die scheiße
es gibt ja auch manchmal so dinge die
sind so zauberhaft wenn wir streiten
sich alle darüber nicht als unsäglich
gut oder ist das unsägliche scheiße und
ich kenne ernstzunehmende
leute die sich mit rap im gegensatz zu
mir auskennen und sagen unglaublich das
kind in die richtung dass es wahnsinnig
kreativ und es gibt leute was redet er
den beiden gab es überhaupt keinen sinn
und so weiter und so fort ja du musst
halt verschiedenen sprachen können um
hart zu verstehen damals für einige
sprachen wir können und das ist halt
auch du musst halt auch irgendwie
tolerant sein manche leute klicken so
ein video an und sehen dann trägt sich
das ist kurde glaube ich einen typen wie
ihr dann mit leuten rum steht um dicken
autos und baseballschläger oder
vielleicht nicht baseballschläger und
denken die rexona sie und hören dann
auch nur diese sachen und sehe nicht
mehr die generalität kollege zum
beispiel so ist also jeder so ein
bankgebäude alles klar ich bin hier der
chef
dann schalten manche schon im kopf ab
auch wenn ihr nicht das video abschalten
und dann soll er sagt ich will urlaub in
georgien machen was machst du da ich
georgien machen
aber sowas musste ja eigentlich auch
erstmal muss das ist hier die schöne
sache und dahinter dann das poetische zu
verstehen schafft halten muss erstmal
ist es so wie irgendwas soap wenn jetzt
irgendwie oder du guckst punkt und und
schaltet da ein und erstmal dass wir
spaß ließ am ende aber dann zehn videos
gesehen was fühlst vielleicht mit den
spaß mit und versteht auch dahinter was
soll die meta-ebene quasi fünf kilometer
eben fünf kilometer ja wunderbar und
welche chancen rechnest du dir aus da
bin ich letztens gefragt wurden wie die
drei in frankfurt dann habe ich gesagt
ich gewinne
hat der junge sogar selber waren max
ferner gesagt das wird aber hartmann
freuen aber ich habe halt lust mich zu
steigern
okay ich hab halt extra meine
qualifikation sehr ruhig mal ich sage
auch ganz ehrlich ich war jetzt noch
eine album vorbereitungsphase viele
videodrehs natürlich kostet zeit aber
macht auch spaß eröffnet möglichkeiten
jetzt bei dir sitzen kostet alles
zeitnah aber sich langsam zu steigen und
vielleicht auch gar nicht so viel es
heißt sei es noch eine menge mehr warten
bis noch luft nach oben so videotechnik
also wer vergleicht doch mal meine
hinrunde mit der rückrunde
rama gesagt über max macht damit heim
und dann ging es direkt los
und nein ich meine ich sagte ja auch
unter uns ganz privat so olli banjo war
für mich ein grund mitzumachen okay weil
er ist auch einer der rapper sowie kool
savas die sich damals genau zu dem
zeitpunkt wo du mit rap viel geld
verdient hast so wie sido bushido und so
haben die sich halt bewusst dafür
entschieden rap zu machen kommen zum
beispiel kool savas und azad haben
jahrelang sich so filme gefahren von
wegen all for one und glaub an dich
bruder und ließen das heißt jahren hat
ihre reichweite dafür genutzten menschen
hoffnung zu machen die vielleicht sonst
abgedriftet wehren und andre haben sie
gedacht ich erreiche gerade die
abgedriftet daraus mache ich jetzt geld
und olli banjo ist halt für mich einer
der allerbesten rapper deutschlands also
auf jeden fall mindestens der top five
wenn nicht sogar top 3 und kaum jemand
weiß das weil wenn olli banjo bock hat
david generation ich versuchte dieses
album kennzeichnen derzeit ist an diese
formation da wachse wenn du dabei und
ich meine welcher rapper hat die schon
speziell wenn eine zuarbeit mehr als
oder waren cassandra steen war dabei und
bin noch sowas bock hat dann macht er so
was wenn deine bock hat auf dem rock
album macht der rock- und das finde ich
vernünftig das ist nämlich ein
authentischer musiker und als ich
gesehen habe dass es im aufruf macht
habe ich mich okay da sind sind
wenigstens leute die am abend davon weil
viele mitbekommen ich bin damals beim
julians blog bettel nicht genommen
worden habe dann gesehen wie viel
leute dann damit gemacht haben die
vielleicht nicht so gut war ist ein team
eine geschmackssache
weil eigentlich gute frage müssen wir
julia noch einmal vor augen den song
gemacht den er bei der gekonnten hat um
ziemlich klein sommer in den augen
seiner mutter hat auch teilweise mehr
aufrufe als die runden gefühl den
hochgeladen es gab ja er hat dann danach
erstmal zwei monate lang gar kein video
mehr hochgeladen
viele haben dann vermutet das hätte ihn
hat richtig wie es getroffen
hinter hat irgendwann in einem seiner
videos oder irgendwo erzählt dass seine
mutter gestorben ist es war auch im
endeffekt nicht sinn der sache wusste
ich auch zu dem zeitpunkt gar nicht aber
es geht einfach nur darum wie kann so
jemand solche videos so eine art von
unterhaltung machen und dabei noch sich
selber oder seiner mutter dann in die
augen schauen und ich glaube ich habe da
aus vielen leuten aus der seele
gesprochen in dem moment aber kann man
dann nicht dazu hat er dann natürlich
nicht veröffentlicht vielleicht weil es
ein konzept zu sehr kritisiert hat auf
dem kanal ist angelaufen
das ist gut gelaufen 700.000 ja dann
sind wir mal gespannt wie das beim rap
spannung mit dir so weitergeht
ich soll spaß machen ich mag es tut mir
leid aber ich fand jetzt den hinrunden
also den sechzehntel gegner nicht so
cool war irgendwie jetzt nicht wo ich
sagen wo die kohle kann gut rappen
es sind auf jeden fall 34 dabei die ich
cool finde beim turnier so also recht
gut finde
und da das würde ich mir wünschen da
auch auf seiner ebene aber weißt du zb
meine mutter hat mich angerufen und also
ich bin jetzt nicht so muttersöhnchen
ich nehme meine mutter und wir sind auch
cool miteinander ist jetzt nicht so dass
alles auch meiner mutter aufbaut nur
trotzdem stehen wir in kontakt und
das gemälde hat gesagt ey was denn da
los und so was machst du denn da und
warum machst du dabei so was mit und so
und was hat der typ gegen dich warum
vertreter der am ende im video eine
brille und so sie konnte das hat gar
nicht verstehen weil das du sie hat
einfach andere welt und ich habe das
dann erst mal erklärt hat dass sie das
nicht so persönlich nehmen soll ich
selber nicht persönlich ich bin ja seit
jahren auf youtube
anhänger kommentare gewöhnt gott sei
dank und es ist halt sport ist wrestling
wenn sie sich das unternehmen ist in die
arme und trinken ein und sagen hey alles
cool so sehe ich das so sehe ich das und
wenn jemand anderes das anders sieht hat
er hat ein problem für mich ist das
verbales kräftemessen und nichts anderes
ok dann sind wir sehr gespannt